hey leute und willkommen zur vorstellung
der neuen minecraft version 1.3 punkt
zwei die gestern beziehungsweise heute
beziehungsweise irgendwann erschienen
ist es sind zwar nicht so viele sachen
dazu gekommen beziehungsweise fast gar
nichts dazu gekommen aber es wurde doch
ein paar sachen gefixed die einzigen
sachen die dazu gekommen sind sind dass
diese bäume nun also diese schrägen
bäume kann man ja nun auch quer
platzieren die wachsen und auch an
bäumen quer
ich hab so woanders jetzt noch nicht
gesehen außer an diesem baum vielleicht
entdeckte das auch noch irgendwo anders
keine ahnung einfach mal ein bisschen
rum fliegen also die erwachsenen auch so
quer an irgendwelchen bäumen
dann wurde bei dem leser portal der bug
gefixed was genau für ein bug das war
weiß ich gar nicht aber bestimmt werden
dass einige von euch wissen also das
wurde jetzt auf jeden fall gefixed dann
wurden ziemlich viele crashes gefixed
wie zum beispiel was ich ganz geil
findet der crash dass man wenn man die
größte pyramide baut werden ich weiß was
ich damit jetzt meine einfach das becken
blog video ansehen dass es unten im
video antworten verlinkt der crash die
minecraft welt teilweise wenn man da
drauf geht unter sich was verzaubert
also das wurde nun auch gefixt
außerdem wurde noch hier multiplayer was
gefixed und zwar wenn man auf
mehrspieler geht und f1 drückt seht ihr
hier
die ip wird ausgeblendet ihr braucht
auch gar nicht versuchen auf den server
zu kommen der whitelist drauf also f1
drücken dann wird das versteckt und
außerdem wurden wurde noch dieser
entdeckungs bug behoben wo genau der war
weiß ich nicht unterhalt noch normale
crashs halt auch alles verbessert also
es gibt wieder na ja hauptsächlich
bugfixes aber es gibt auch wieder nun
die möglichkeit dass wenn ihr die 1.3.1
habt könnt ihr trotzdem auf dem server
mit der 1.3 punkt 21 punkte punkt 2
könnt ihr trotzdem office server
draufgehen der mit 1.3.1 kompatibel ist
also so typische sachen und ich dachte
ich mach einfach mal wieder damit jetzt
trotzdem etwas neues und ja ich würde
mich freuen wenn sie beim nächsten mal
zschau